and when I woke up they had me nasally
innovated because of all the oral trauma
and I reached up and I pulled that hose
out of my out of my nose oh [__] that
pain woke me up and that's when they
that's when they basically had me out of
that comb I was I was breathing on my
own and then I see the doctor and I'm
I'm so doped up still in this state of
mind and trying to figure out what just
happened to process what happened and
the first thing the doctor tells me he's
like we managed to save your your leg
and when he told me managed to save my
leg I'm just like you know baffled like
what the hell just happened also he said
leg I got two of them you know what I'm
saying
bro I got two legs doc what the [__] are
you talking about
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
okay